idris good to see you man i'm good to
see you guys
i'm curious over the course of making
this whole thing
if anybody was concerned that you were
making this character too sexy
nobody was concerned with uh him being
sexy i mean you know he's he's a brawny
guy but sexy pill i don't know
yeah
but you you like him there must be
something you really like about because
you're you're doing this serious too
right and another movie all right listen
yeah if that happens i'm really excited
it's uh they've said they want to do
that and that's like incredible and i do
like him i i like
i like doing voice work and i and sonic
is such a big character you know it's
great i love it
so
you have said in the past that you've
had pretty much every like video game
system
when you were growing up what what would
you say is your greatest video game
accomplishment
uh wow good question um i think my uh
what did i i finished um
i finished uncharted once
yeah and i'm not i think it might have
been uncharted four but i finished that
game i don't finish games i play stages
and then get frustrated but this one
i stuck to the whole storylines i
watched all the films i did the extras
yeah you're dedicated dedicate 100.
when you are in the booth recording what
kind of actor are you when you're in the
booth are you really are you as animated
as the character are you out there are
you sweating what's it like for you in
that booth yeah i'm committed 100
committed like if you like i was saying
if you pull back and watch me work from
afar you would think something odd was
going on with me because i'm throwing my
voice about and doing the movements and
uh there's no doubt every time like i do
my voice my mic comes off because i've
just
you know they're like it's just we're
not filming you we're recording your
voice but for me it's important to be
able to get the energy in the body to
get the base to be you know
yeah
i was in a theater full of kids
watching this movie and like the the
laughs and the oohs and the odds like
the reaction was number one it was super
heartwarming to actually be with the
group like that again but for you like
how much does it mean to you to get that
reaction from young people because we
know like a lot of adults love your work
but when we
you know when you watch a movie your
movie that young people are reacting to
what's that like for you yeah that's the
best feeling man that's a bit i've done
a few films that have you know really
been you know uh embraced by young
people and it just feels wicked i you
know they don't know who i am they just
know oh that's that guy from
zootopia that's that guy knuckles you
know and i i love that they don't know
my name but it's very satisfying for
them to uh
you know recognize my voice you know
what i mean i love that
yeah and finally before i let you go um
jim carrey had been talking recently
about the idea of retirement and that
you know he's he's ready he feels like
he's done enough did you have any any
thoughts on that like i know myself
being a huge jim carrey fan it does it
never feels like it's enough but
you know
it's another perspective right
he's someone that could probably keep
going forever and ever you know uh he's
he's got such an inventive mind as many
of his characters
i but i can understand you know when
you've done so much you've made so many
people happy ah you know you want to
hang in the towel gracefully but
it would be a sad day i think
yeah well man listen
so great catching up with you
had a lot of fun with this movie uh
can't wait to see what's next for you
and knuckles thanks carlos appreciate
that